I'm a Mandalorian Mirka we're here to
entertain the audience that are here and
we're here to
some fun with everybody else right so
tell me about these costumes that you're
gonna hear because they're really
impressive well we're all custom
Mandalorians
from Star Wars and based on Boba Fett's
and the expanded universe and we will
make our own armor do you work off some
kind of I don't know a model or a plan
or a pattern or something when you're
when you're building something like this
or is it just from what you see in the
film well let's be by soft the
Mandalorians the basic plate structure
in the helmet we have certain rules that
you have to follow and generally you
tend to either need to look like Boba
Fett or Jango Fett or any sort of thing
from the expanded universe such as the
legacy area or even earlier in the game
such as Knights of the Old Republic so
we generally have a certain set of rules
that you have to follow to do
do you costume and most people are the
following it by making their own
templates in sizing it to your
individual body size and so forth as on
either the armor larger person I have a
larger plates but there are smaller
people have smaller helmets and smaller
stuff in the expanded universe it's at
Mandalorians as a culture as has really
really grown and one of the major parts
of it is that each Mandalorian is
individual and they paint their armor
individually depending on on what the
things they've seen or what things I've
done or what rules they go through you
know whether they have a parents plate
on their armor and so forth so each
armor actually tells a story for every
individual Mandalorian miraculous that's
a scratch there cost you oh so tell me
about your story then mine it's
generally just a character who went to
Tatooine and created a tradition of
fighting crack dragons so the mark of
Honor is the crack dragon on the pocket
can you turn around for the camera so we
can see the lovely dragon that you've
got on the side there fantastic
and how about you what's your particular
story in the way that you've customized
your particular costume
well actually I'm still working on my
character story at the moment and I'm
kind of build it in terms of my costume
and tell them a question down here we
have the chest island plates from
previous members of my family that's
pretty much as far as I've got them with
Baxter at the moment really it's a work
in progress so we say exactly exactly
what is it like under those costumes
because I can imagine it's gonna get
pretty hot than a hot day on Tatooine if
you've got your own kind of finished or
nothing going on inside there I haven't
because I've actually got fans inside my
helmet you can you might actually hear
them coming through and a different
voice but so it only keeps me quite a
variety dan keeps air flowing around
there the important thing is is that you
need to sweat the problem is a lot of
people try to stop sweating and that's
where you start getting into real
trouble you've just got to allow
yourself to sweat and you've got to
allow the air to take the sweat away
which cools you down but it is a bit of
a steaming moment when you take your
help.you stuff off at the end of the day
if you've got fans going on inside there
as well be taking a leaf out this book
sadly not know and you have a small vent
at the back of my helmet which does help
there's natural airflow but not yet well
thing to work on for the future guys get
fantastic enjoy the weekend here
you